that name I didn't want to believe it
because how why
a family living through grief all over
again with the man who killed their
loved one while driving high on drugs is
accused of doing the same thing again it
is a story our eight news now
investigators broke right here last
night thank you for joining us at six
I'm Brian Loftus I'm Kirsten Joyce 50
year old Prentice Bates was driving High
when he killed a motorcyclist 10 years
ago and just yesterday police say he was
driving impaired again when he killed
another driver the family of his first
victim speaking exclusively with eight
news now investigator David Charles
David this has to be so incredibly
heartbreaking for them yeah Brian not
only heartbreaking but also super
frustrating Jim burchett's family says
they weren't notified Prentice Bates was
even out of prison until they saw our
story
this was a man who decided to
become impaired and get behind a wheel
of a car
and he took a person's life he took my
Dad's life Bert Burchette has no remorse
for a 50 year old Prentice Bates The Man
convicted of driving high in killing his
dad he would go out every Sunday and
ride on a Sunday in November 2012 Jim
burchett went out on his bike he didn't
come home alive I kept calling my dad I
couldn't couldn't get through to him a
police report says Bates hit Burchette
head on near Nellis and Cheyenne
documents the eight news now
investigators obtained say he had no
driver's license had a suspended license
in California for a prior DUI and that
he was driving someone else's rental car
we arrived home the coroner was here
it was in this room we found out
that he had killed that room now filled
with memories of Burchette who would be
celebrating his 40th wedding anniversary
this year Bates serving eight years in
prison for the fatal DUI documents
revealing He was ordered to have an
interlocking device put on his car after
his release but this June Metro Police
charging him with another DUI a judge
setting bail in that case at fifty
thousand dollars Bates made bond and was
back on the road police saying Thursday
morning he hit and killed a second
person this time near Rancho and Craig
this other death was preventable
it was preventable on on his part and it
was preventable on the system's part
Friday for his most recent deadly DUI
accusation prosecutors did not hold back
he is a danger to the community he has
killed now two people
now the judge today not giving Bates
bail he will have another hearing next
week and records show Bates was granted
parole in August 2020 and then released
that November I'm David charns 8 News
Now
the victim in this week's fatal crash
identified as 40-year-old Damar Sims we
are working to find out if Bates owned
the vehicle police say he was driving in
for the latest crash